moi je me déplace beaucoup en voiture
entre deux expos je prends les petites
routes j'ai toujours mon appareil photo
et dès qu'il ya une lumière intéressante
il suffit qu'il ya un troupeau de vaches
ou de chevaux à côté une bonne lumière
je m'arrête je vais les voir je passe du
temps avec je regarde l'animal qui va
m'intéresser à peindre cet intérêt pour
les animaux c'est d'abord de la
bienveillance du respect et même un peu
d'admiration
quand gilles captons traduit ses
émotions sur la toile il magnifie le
sujet sous son pinceau cette vache
africaine gagne en force en beauté il
lui offre aussi un petit surplus
d'humanité en portrait disant l'animal
mois ses cadrages l'âme m'intéresse
vraiment des portraits j'aime bien au
repas portrait humain mais portraits
d'animaux parce que je pense que vous
aussi c'est très important de les avoir
près de nous à côté de nous voilà ne pas
avoir un dominé par rapport à un
dominant m à côté l'un de l'autre
donc je trouve que ça ça c'est
intéressant
pourquoi le cadrage de ces animaux c'est
aussi ça
[Musique]
dans tout
l'art du cadrage couplée à une technique
très maîtrisée des contrastes c'est
l'explication du succès de gilles
captant formée aux beaux-arts d'orléans
il y a près de 40 ans l'artiste est
désormais reconnue dans sa propre ville
après l'avoir été à paris et en europe
ses toiles sous la thématique d'un
voyage africain sont à voir à saint jean
le blanc jusqu'au 16 décembre
[Musique]